But I often found out that I was the yuki-onna at that time My
face and whiteness haven't changed Is it a mistake
?
That's not bad
either, you know me well It's
been more than 10 years since then. Your face should have changed as you look older, but you
're the only person I remember helping you recently.  It's
not like I'm looking at people in the air There
are signs and colors that don't change easily
[music]
I was worried that I wasn't able to repay my debts enough  I
can buy
dozens of soft-serve ice cream that have
increased.  I
don't know about credit cards, service days, or other people's calendars. All I have is
windows.  It's also
suitable for eating without worrying about others.